sentiment d'urgence sur la caravane
libéral six avaient à un rythme effréné
dans le sud de l'ontario à l'offensive
quitte à s'écorcher la voix le chef
libéral veut montrer qu'il se bat
toujours pour obtenir une majorité
nous allons continuer de travailler très
fort pour élire un gouvernement
progressiste et contrer ni coupure
conservatrice mais le spectre d'un
gouvernement minoritaire est bien réelle
interrogé à répétition justin trudeau
refuse de dire s'il accepterait de faire
coalition pour contrer les conservateurs
le chef libéral mais plutôt en garde
contre les conséquences d'un vote pour
le bloc ou le npd
au contraire on a vu ce qui s'est passé
pendant dix ans de stephen harper où on
a eu un effet des phares et même un bloc
fort à ottawa a coupé dans la culture a
reculé sera sur kyoto et sur les
protection de l'environnement
une remarque qui fait bondir le chef du
bloc québécois et justin je te le
rappelle en 2008 là c'est vous autres
qui avait permis aux conservateurs vous
autres qui avait permis aux
conservateurs de couper dans les arts et
la culture du québec le bloc a voté
contre le budget les libéraux se sont
abstenus john meeting du npd qui a été
le premier à évoquer une coalition avec
les libéraux semblaient maintenant
vouloir éviter le sujet pour moi ce
n'est pas une question de collection
cette question de nos priorités qui sont
les prêts étaient des gens c'est clair
que c'est un trio va fermer n'importe
quoi pour rester au pouvoir
ce qui n'a pas empêché le chef
conservateur de souligner les dangers
d'un tel scénario
le problème est que une coalition entre
chiens trudeau et l'entraidé va coûter
les canadiens plus cher va augmenter les
impôts avant
tuer les emplois et rendre la vie à plus
cher justin trudeau se garde bien de
prononcer le mot coalition faisant le
calcul que cela pourrait peut-être
envoyer un signal de faiblesse
à une semaine du scrutin et favoriser
encore davantage l'érosion du vote
libéral ici louis blouin radio-canada a
menti